les joueurs de rugby rongent leur frein
de retour à l'entraînement mais privé de
toute épreuve de force
l'objectif c'est tenter de commencer à
pouvoir faire du touch rugby donc sans
contact mais j'ai comme un peu comme un
peu chacun donc tu touches très
rapidement c'est vrai que reprendre le
contact faire claquer quelques usa en
entraide d'or de ressentir la chaleur
humaine au football universitaire les
joueurs des carabins champion québécois
s'entraîne avec prudence des infections
distanciation sont les moutons comme à
l'habitude à ce stade-ci de l'année il
ne s'agit que de séances de
conditionnement physique sans uniforme
ni ballon la ligue québécoise est la
seule au canada à maintenir l'espoir
d'une saison l'otan n'a pas contacté
est-ce qu'on peut adapter certains
aspects du jeu oui définitivement
mais je pense qu'à un moment un effort
décider à qui mais là ça commence à être
trop ou un courage hors football québec
de recevoir le feu vert de la direction
du sport de loisir et de l'activité
physique pour préparer ces calendriers
en vue d'une saison début septembre
en ce moment seuls des joueurs d'âge
mineur pratiquer le football
les contacts entre coéquipiers sont
permis mais les duels face à des rivaux
sont interdits l'âge avancé de nombreux
arbitres pourrait cependant causer un
problème on m'a vraiment beaucoup derby
actuellement on assez mais la
particularité de ces arbitres souvent
sont pas tous mais en a plusieurs qui
sont rangés ça pourrait rapidement
catastrophique nous d'avoir des arbitres
sont infectés puis de voir les met en
quarantaine au rugby la saison devait
commencer en mai
aujourd'hui l'essentiel c'est d'arriver
à jouer avec cette intensité avant
l'hiver
permettent de faire les comptes en
caisse et c'est ce qui nous drive jean
françois poirier radio canada montréal